Oh
I mean certainly there are
representative artists in all the fields
who did blossom in later life I think
the ability to express oneself
artistically again it might be a worry
and a question about social stereotyping
you know people might assume that people
as they get older are going to decline
in their capacity to be creatively
expressive so I mean just if you talk to
older actors about the about you know
the the ability to get roles and acting
as an older actor you know that I think
they would see that as as greatly
declining opportunity because our
society has sort of been biased against
you know the older person in media in
the arts so so there there's a worry
about being able to continue creative
expression depending on the field that
you're in but having said that you know
with aging comes great life experience
and you know there's a lot of interest
in what happens to brain function as
people get older and a lot of worry
about loss of memory and dementia but
there's real you know there's real data
that wisdom is something that is accrued
with life experience and so there's that
whole there's that whole field of
experience and wisdom which which would
kind of feed into creativity and the
older person being able to you know
manifest their life's experience in
their wisdom so so I certainly like to
believe that one's ability to be
creative and to grow I mean I think I
think growing in new directions is kind
of a hallmark of successful aging so
some of the you know historically
interesting figures who really aged well
took up new forms of creative expression
as they got older like
Grandma Moses you know the artist or it
said that Albert Einstein I believe took
up playing the violin in late life and
so so exploring new routes of creativity
is one of the hallmarks of of people who
age well
you know one of the most effective ways
of keeping your brain function as you
get older is to stay healthy in general
we know that for instance all of the
risk factors that you hear about for
heart disease for instance high blood
pressure diabetes smoking you know
having an inactive lifestyle though all
of those things that put you at risk in
other realms of health are also risk
factors for brain and disease and
Alzheimer's disease so so you know
staying healthy it's all the things that
you kind of wish weren't the things you
had to do because they're not the easy
things to do you know we we all want to
be able to pop a pill and that's going
to preserve our memory but it's really
you know eating a healthy diet staying
physically active I mean if I had to say
the one thing that that people really
should try to do beginning in early life
that will have huge payback you know as
they get older is is creating habits of
physical activity you know being an
active person I mean that's just I call
it the real fountain of you if it really
is I mean exercise has been shown to
prevent many diseases that are
associated with aging and it's all it's
also been shown to really maintain brain
function as well so you know eating a
healthy diet staying physically active
continuing to be mentally and socially
engaged continuing to be involved in
whatever whatever is your passion you
know to really be engaged with life
those have all been shown to really
promote preserved brain function
we still don't you know we still don't
know what causes Alzheimer's disease and
that is just a subjective huge amount of
research going on so so of course it's
true that brilliant people get
alzheimer's disease and you know it's a
very tragic disease but if you look at
you know the whole population if people
pursued healthier lifestyles that would
that would
a big plus in terms of preserving brain
function across the population
there's just reams of research data that
prove that point that physical activity
is you know as I said it it plays out as
preventing many diseases it's a it's a
strong predictor of mortality if you
look at and this is you know been shown
in numerous research studies if you look
at people's exercise capacity how able
they are to be vigorously active it's a
very strong predictor of how long you
live and for each you know increment up
on the scale you are a physical activity
the longer you would be I mean it would
predict for your length of life the good
news is that you know you don't have to
be a marathon runner I mean if you're so
because you know people get discouraged
they're like well I've been a couch
potato all my life but if you even go
from like the lowest quartile of
physical activity to the second to the
lowest quartile you really improve your
your your health status and as I said
you know just a broad range of diseases
whether it's hypertension heart disease
colon cancer depression diabetes I mean
I you know I could read a long list but
all of those things are reduced in
incidents in people that are physically
active so you know that's the tragedy -
of what we're seeing now I mean I really
look at young people now even kids I
mean you know as a geriatrician I'm
really coming to see more and more that
everything begins in early life so you
know the fact that kids now aren't
active you know they're not going out to
ride their bikes and explore the
neighborhood they're sitting at home you
know behind their computers which I mean
there's some there's some benefit there
- I think that modern day access to
information is just remarkable but you
know kids not being physically active
you know recess being done away with at
schools and and the rate of childhood
obesity is just terribly frightening
it's considered one of the leading
Public Health you know issues in this
country is the rate of childhood obesity
because that is just going to play out
into you know adults being obese it's
that's already a huge number
and it's it's said that now this next
generation as the baby boomers move into
the elderly age group it might start to
be true that people live less long than
their than their parents and that's
gonna be because obesity which really a
big part of it is that obesity leading
to type 2 diabetes and all of the
problems with with diabetes and
premature death so you know it's really
scary so I kind of you know I really
applaud all the efforts that are going
on now to try to turn that around to
reduce obesity to get kids to be more
active I think that's really going to be
a key to what you know what we're seeing
down the line in terms of the elderly